olha só eu a 27
essa casa em tem passado muitos alunos
meus e comecei a ficar um caso de
resultado com o tempo com as bases ou
outros começaram a aparecer
é nos últimos anos
vamos falar das outras como questões nem
sabem que são sustentabilidade
eficiência inovação é veículos ou seja
palavras também estamos nas palavras
hoje são as palavras uma pessoa não vai
trabalhar numa loja vai ser colaboradora
colaboradora na frança que é escrava um
faz tudo o que faço
no final não ser direto o pessoal está
aqui muita gente de gestão que gosta tem
muitas que vazou dos montes de gestão
então tem razões a traseira é eu gosto
de dizer que eu gostei muito daqui é
multi power light
gostei muito power power light power bom
em relação aos veículos elétricos eu sou
é o centro dessa disciplina já faz seis
anos e meu objetivo com com as pessoas e
com vocês só então tinham mais novo é
tentar abrir a cabeça e tentar pelo
menos 19 certas pessoas que não estão cá
que as pessoas trocam soltaria suspensas
entre os gêneros deixem enganar lógico
bom então é eu fui fazendo algumas
palestras na minha cadeira e foi
convidado pelo meu aluno eu não vai
chumbar támbém não vai chumbar mas o meu
aluno para fazer uma palestra sobre é
eventos elétricos ponto em que o
eléctrico na nossa cabeça
nós pensamos logo que o livro é
pequenino tradicional não é que é o sol
é o que os peões que parecem os anúncios
só completo vai desde de aviões comboios
autocarros certo
estamos a falar também de pequenos de
táxis vale o valor do montante mundial
de coisas que já existem pelo menos há
20 ou 30 anos
mas há uma alma uma má gestão para as
pessoas para verem o vt elétrico como o
anúncio quando rosa eu gostei eu peço
desculpas aqui pelo apelo pela pela
junção
mas eu sei que é isso que eu gostei
muito
este anúncio para mim estudo tá eu não
sou contra eventos elétricos já vamos
dizer o colega posição que eu tenho é
esse anúncio é que ela nos lucros em fio
pela garganta em que aparece gente de
todo tipo vejam que aqui agrada a todo
mundo a agradar todo mundo tem tudo já
estava indo pra fazer um marketing está
vai fazer depois temos um veículo limpo
em uma rua limpa tudo maravilhoso
eu vou aplicar vocês eu quero ficar opa
o fla está aqui tá mal depois foi buscar
isso é simples mais uma para os venderem
é tudo limpo quem me dera ter um
estacionamento e se em lisboa que no
taguspark a partir do meio dia quando
não tem lugar para estacionar não é
limpo tal um carro que o tudo
maravilhoso não há riscos no carro você
já viu um óbvio que marcou minha
infância eu não sou contra depois tem
anúncios destes temos um powerpoint
andar a fazer isso aqui é uma figura
feita
se vocês forem olhar que foi feito nos
autocarros da vida outros outros
softwares e isto faz lembrar uma cidade
que os consumidores se uma cidade da
barbie onde correu mundo que as pessoas
vivem corre planeta que estou a viver
isso faz lembrar uma coisa uma vez que a
audi foi lá o técnico fazer uma palestra
para casa tínhamos alguns
posicionamentos lá e conseguir ficar
nervoso com sua passar um vídeo que era
uma cidade maravilhosa estradas largas
tudo é tudo cinzento a quem perguntar ao
vídeo aqui
depois aparece um saldo dos audi a8
lindo furo tona lindo não há
engarrafamentos na nato e e também aqui
na escola técnica
eu estou a tentar passar uma mensagem
para os alunos com as pessoas que vão lá
para fora então a tentar
enganar out mas que coisa é essa eu não
vou dizer que o mundo é mundo a barbie
não existe isso
vamos em frente ó eu gostei muito desta
isto é quem diz o seguinte vamos pensar
sem nunca é demais que eles não eu vou
lutar por nossa cabeça é o seguinte cada
carro que os normais são 400 quilos
baterias são 400 quilos
ninguém nos diz como é que os fazem as
baterias para fazer realmente todas as
baterias é preciso buscar a queimar
muito mais coisas
precisa-se novos pneus primeiros não
aguentar aquela pressão toda ou seja o
peso todo vamos mais enfrentar isto é a
realidade está a unidade que enquanto
todos os dias que eu vou daqui de euros
para pagar o técnico às sete da manhã
todos os dias tem ficado pior todos os
gostos
não venham dizer que eu vou substituir
todos os carros que vêm dos elétricos
como vai ficar nervoso quando fazem
mentira não é mais fácil para carros
não há mais espaço para carros não há
gente a gente vê isso em todas as
cidades grandes não há mais espaço para
carros
quem vai daqui por esgotado disso
ninguém vai de 1 a 8 certo e vai vai com
o carro elétrico é o caminho não vai não
vendo essa imagem errada
bom agora é a questão
onde está o lugar para os chamados
designados veículos elétricos também
transporte transporte os automóveis
táxis
os táxis em frança que eu tenho pra casa
um exemplo de ontem do lyon todos são
híbridos elétricos
essa emoção essa ideia porque o táxi
assim vai parar devagarinho e em vista
estar triste ver o time está um motor
elétrico a bateria mas o eficiência
enorme
a gente sabe que gasta um outro de ontem
um monte de co2 que o pessoal gosta
muito dizendo co2 o céu dos lacres de
placas pelas vacas é tão cheio mas não
foi do jeito dele é ver nada
o acordo é treta já vou te dizer outra
mas vocês têm táxis os comuns
hoje os achamos autocarros junto a
castro aqueles que alunas em dados
sim preparar a arrancar para arrancar
nas baixas sociedade
o veículo elétrico é o lugar dele
dúvidas não são testados aqui o vento
elétrico entra quando o motor elétrico
entre a marcha dos indignados porque com
deficiência dele é enorme mas como esse
com essa certa vez numa das baterias das
baterias é o fígado
deste lado também aí é o filho no carro
o problema dos carros - é isso mas já
pensa em segundo
são tão antigos antigos implementar até
o fórum tem o fórum tempo em baterias
normais eo normal
não se sabe se foi abandonado em 1989
porque o petróleo descoberto no texas
que teve petróleo até dizer chega
depois foi para fora já fui inventar até
carros de corrida havia na bélgica
sabia disso mas eu sabia pensava
bom agora vão saber uma coisa e quando
fui convidado dessa palestra e aos meus
alunos deus eu costumo dizer pelo menos
para pensar e falar crítica não engulam
as coisas não engula o carro elétrico
hoje pra mim é um smartphone estão a
manter os carros que hoje pode estar nós
somos as grandes empresas naquela quadra
toda
nós somos cobaias
se cada carro tem 400 quilos
tivemos pelo menos mil carros eu estou
lá nas baterias o que está a fazer com
elas mas há dois anos depois foi embora
as que são seis anos de gestão na na
garantia eu sabe quanto dura e só depois
o juiz acha que os fazem em pistas que
não têm para arrancar é é é é um cidadão
que não é normal
sim eu sempre bato agora uma vez eu
gosto do símbolo
james é um gato é por exemplo eu já dei
exemplos aqui em lisboa é substituir os
táxis com o fazem em frança que é todos
elétricos vindos porque tá 100 para
arrancar e som ou seja um veículo
elétrico é bom para baixas nos cuidados
a gente tenta acelerar e desacelerar e
até mesmo urina a gente sabe disso
a gente sabe disso e não só contra quem
é que faz os ventos elétricos com
sucesso a panacéia do mundo inteiro tá
bem que vai salvar o mundo não vai mesmo
não há mais lugar para casa cheia de
bênção da mãe
a mercedes é uma coisa que eu gosto eu
sabem que daqui a 25 30 anos ea minha
filha está lá em cima o flamengo vai
entrar nessa
nessa onda não vai poder ver carros
próprias não vai poder não há lugar para
ter carro jeito não há não a gente sabe
isso não a faz ter vocês vêem a gente
foi que todos já em agosto quando as
pessoas vêm cá a gente mora aqui vai
para lá em agosto não recebe subsídio
com essa pra cá todos os anos é
condenado carlos marchena antigamente a
gente e mail saía era uma maravilha não
havia ninguém no estado
depois eu passei a ir até 2015
agora você é chato e mesmo assim não
faltará gente olha para trás só viesse
uma espécie de lavar ou seja são faróis
e luzes vermelhas não se dissipou chega
todo mundo elogiou a limpeza no local
funcionários bom um bom transporte
eu sei que cerca a voz ao contrário mas
não é ser uma voz ao contrário é vocês
pensarem um bocadinho querem outra coisa
vocês vão ouvir muito falar de
recuperação de energia né
veículos travam então energia que a
gente tem disse neto que o movimento vai
ser publicada todas as baterias certo
então vamos ver vou passar o dia inteiro
acelerar o trabalho
se vocês forem ver ali energia cinética
- e poucos quilos nos 80 quilômetros
eu tenho que parar faça as contas isso
dá uma lâmpada serrote a funcionar
durante uma hora
nada de andar pra nada só se passar um
dia inteiro a travar a arrancada
trabalha trabalha trabalha agora no
combóio tem um lado os caminhões de
entregas têm toneladas aviões têm tom
alas
aí sim os combates já fazem isso um
caminhão de entregas que eu digo em
lisboa só que nem estão sempre lá dentro
frota já não fazem os estados unidos e
alguns países da europa e chegar a gente
sempre atrasado
são fotos são inimigas porque sabem que
aquele carro são pesados estão sendo
arrancada e parar o tratamento usar a
parte elétrica e aí sim não vou
praticamente quem mata do desterro
ninguém ea frota de criação até salvos
para carregarem de acordo com o operador
vejam procurar gente está está na nossa
na nossa laudos um caso no passado uma
exposição de automóveis
rio um colega meu foi lá
já acabei só foi lá e vi em cima de um
carro estava um painel fotovoltaico a
menina havia uma menina
sinto muito senhor para chamar as
pessoas venham porque tem que o painel
fotovoltaico aqui o carro não vai ter
vai poder economizar nos dias em que o
painel dá pra
hoje a europa só pra manter o rádio do
carro e vi um senhor de dados um casal
que achavam realmente quem comprar um
carro aqui hoje porque a economizar
gasolina sequer se não fosse o meu
colega está lá só explicar eu só quero
jogar no máximo para acender o carro o
rádio digital tentar vindo ótimo 30
horas
isso me deixou chateado
deixam chateado que faça essa geração
nova que só vocês em cada a mesma forma
o saco de vocês eu só tô aqui pra você
curtir um caminho não se deixem
olímpicos pelos besouros e avós não
deixa seja humanos
eu gostei muito das emoções em outra
senhora tem aqui é um ano ser humano a
humano é respeitar o consumidor mas
também está empregado
não é que eu posso trabalhar no amazonas
a gente sabe que a amazon a escravos
elas vêm cá para fora
por isso há um ano fora humano dentro
errado